la frénésie immobilière et vous dans le
cadre de notre semaine spéciale sur
l'immobilier nous vous proposons ce soir
des conseils pour les acheteurs avec
nous la notaire yasmine bensalem bonsoir
bonsoir
alors pour mettre la main sur une
résidence en ce moment il ya beaucoup
d'acheteurs qui doivent se précipiter et
certains vont jusqu'à laisser tomber
l'inspection en ce moment est ce que
c'est la pire chose à faire selon vous
est ce que c'est la pire chose à faire
je vous dirais que non on voit des
achats faits sans inspection mais je
vous dirais qu'il faut peser faut savoir
peser le pour et le contre et voir un
petit peu le risque dans lequel on est
en train de s'embarquer parce que ça
dépend est ce que j'achète une maison
que les propriétaires actuels ont depuis
40 ans puis qui a été construite dans
les années 50 où est ce que j'achète un
condo une nouvelle construction
construite il ya moins de 5 ans donc ça
va faire une différence parce que quand
on parle des nouvelles constructions des
condos la nouvelle construction
souvent on voit qu'il ya une garantie de
d'habitations neuves qui vient avec
l'achat d'un condo
et puis ce qui est beau c'est que
habituellement cette garantie est là
elle est transférable donc si le terme
de la garantie en général il est de cinq
ans donc si moi j'achète je rachète le
condo du premier propriétaire moins de
cinq ans après la construction je vais
bénéficier de cette garantie la gauche
mais est ce que c'est quand même
acceptable dans certaines conditions de
dire je l'espère d'inspection en tant
que notaire c'est dur pour moi de vous
dire laisser tomber inspection mais je
voudrais que dans certaines situations
dans certains contextes et pas la fin du
monde de para ok d'affaires d'inspection
on voit aussi des propriétés qui sont à
vendre en excluant la garantie légale
quels sont les risques d'acheter une
propriété déjà faut savoir la garantie
légale c'est une garantie automatique
une garantie standard c'est la loi le
code civil du québec prévoit que quand
on achète une propriété au québec
la garantie légale vient protéger
l'acheteur par contre la garantie légale
elle peut absolument être exclue si
personne ne parle de la garantie légale
automatiquement la garantie légale
protège l'acheteur mais le vendeur peut
l'exclure il faut que cela soit écrit
mot pour mot en général on va voir
quelque chose du genre
cet immeuble cette maison est vendue
sans garantie légale aux risques et
périls de l'acheteur aux risques et
périls dollar
fait important à retenir du coup si on
achète une maison sans garantie légale
ça veut pas nécessairement dire qu'il ya
anguille sous roche il ya certes un
contexte où certaines situations où la
garantie légale est exclu par habitude
disons dans le cas de vente de
succession quelqu'un hérite d'une maison
il n'a jamais habité cette maison il n'a
jamais l'occasion de d'entretenir cette
maison il n'a pas envie de se tenir
garant de la garantie donc il retire la
garantie légale parce que faut savoir la
garantie légale qu'est ce que ça veut
dire concrètement c'est que en tant que
vendeur on est responsable des vices
cachés et davies légaux or si on l'a
jamais habité on pourrait vouloir
l'exclure pour éviter de tomber dans le
panneau de la surenchère en ce moment
qu'une information un acheteur
devrait-il y trouver alors il y a
tellement d'informations disponibles
pour toute personne c'est pas juste les
notaires ou les courtiers qui y ont
accès c'est de l'information publique il
faut juste l'avocat qui s'est pas caché
ses publics
des fois c'est gratuit ou quasiment
gratuit faut juste savoir où aller la
chercher
je commence par le registre foncier du
québec
donc le registre foncier du québec
qu'ils ont un site en ligne c'est de
l'information publique toute personne
peut y accéder il faut juste savoir
comment s'y prendre le registre foncier
du québec c'est bien simple ça nous
montre toutes les transactions tout ce
qui s'est passé sur l'épreuve sur une
propriété donnée au québec depuis sa
construction et même avant parce qu'on
parle du lot ce qu'il faut savoir par
contre c'est que les recherches registre
foncier ça coûte un dollar la
consultation mais la recherche elle se
fait par numéro de lot et non par
adresse donc pour avoir accès aux
numéros de lot ça aussi c'est de
l'information publique toute personne
n'y a accès donc le numéro de lot on
peut soit le retrouver sur le site de la
municipalité
il ya beaucoup de municipalités qui ont
ce qu'on appelle leur rôle foncier en
ligne donc on va sur un moteur de
recherche on tape rôle foncier montréal
re foncier laval rôle foncier de
montagne et puis sur le site internet
normalement on devrait retrouver le
numéro de lot sinon si on n'est pas
capable de faire ça on appelle la
municipalité on dit bonjour j'aimerais
connaître le numéro de lot associé à
telle adresse c'est de l'information
publique on va vous le donner et sur le
registre foncier on peut retrouver
l'acte de vente du propriétaire actuel
donc c'est une foule d'informations c
peut avoir accès aux prix de vente au
prix d'achat du propriétaire actuel est
ce qu'il ya des hypothèques inscrits sur
la propriété est ce qu'une roue potec
sont en défaut pas mal d'informations
précieuses est-ce qu'on devrait obtenir
d'avancées une préautorisation
hypothécaires avant de déposer une offre
absolument absolument surtout dans un
marché en pleine frénésie
comme on a en ce moment une pré
approbation ça nous rend un petit peu
plus sérieux aux yeux d'un vendeur en ce
moment on entend beaucoup parler des
offres multiples d d d autres qui rentre
au dessus du prix affiché
donc nous aussi en tant qu'acheteur ont
fait une offre mais qu'elle est
conditionnelle à l'approbation notre
prêt hypothécaire puis qu'on a même pas
de pré approbation a montré aux vendeurs
on va sans doute se faire écarter du
coup je le recommande absolument
ici on nous demande de faire un dépôt
lorsqu'on fait une offre
est ce que l'acheteur qu'est-ce qu'est
ce que l'acheteur doit vraiment
surveiller pour pas se faire avoir
alors je voudrais l'élément le plus
important c'est que oui c'est comment tu
ça arrive là qu'un vendeur demande une
offre justement pour attester la du
sérieux de l'acheteur mais avant de vous
engager avant de signer quoi que ce soit
assurez-vous que ce soit écrit mot pour
mot très clairement que l'offre est
remboursable si jamais la propriété
n'est pas acheter et autrement moi je
voudrais que l'offre bain pour être
vraiment certain fait là au notaire
l'offre elle peut être fait le dépôt par
dans le dépôt peut être fait aux
vendeurs aux courtiers s'il y en a un où
on à terre ce serait peut-être mieux en
tant que notaire moi je vous recommande
de faire faire votre dépôt aux notaires
et de vous assurer que c'est écrit que
c'est remboursables en cas de encore de
quoi on sait remboursable si jamais la
propriété n'est pas acheter sinon le
dépôt est simplement déduit de la mise
de fonds
parfait vous êtes de bons conseils merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit